voilà et dans le même temps l'hiver lui
arrive notamment en Ukraine et avec lui
la neige et le froid surtout de quoi
inquiéter à corps que les coupures de
courant sont toujours très fréquentes
pour faire le point sur la situation
plus largement en Ukraine on va
retrouver en direct notre correspondant
dans le pays Gulliver crack bonjour
Gulliver un mot tout d'abord avec vous
que sait-on Gulliver de la situation
dans les territoires
occupés
oui je voulais juste un peu rebondir sur
ce sujet de France 2 qu'on vient de
passer dans les territoires occupés il y
a bien sûr des collaborants il y a des
gens qui sont pro-ukrainiens mais qui
c'était se cache ou s'enfuit et il y a
aussi dans certaines localités des
résistants et aujourd'hui ils se font
entendre puisque des résistants dans la
ville de novaka Roca qui est une ville
assez importante dans la région de
Herson qui reste
occupé sur les bords du Nièvre ils ont
communiqué que ils ont observé le départ
de certains collaborons haut placé ce
que les Russes avaient mis dans des
positions d'autorité dans la ville alors
bien sûr cela lance beaucoup de
spéculations en Ukraine sur pourquoi
est-ce qu'ils partent est-ce qu'ils
savent quelque chose est-ce qu'ils ont
peur de nouvelles avancées de l'armée
ukrainienne alors la situation à novaka
Roca et peut-être quelque chose à suivre
dans les prochains jours ou les
prochaines semaines
bonjour ni un autre ennemi pour les
Ukrainiens en ce moment c'est le froid
l'hiver arrive peu à peu il fait à peu
près 0° à Kiev vous vous trouvez quel
est l'état de des infrastructures de
l'électricité du chauffage dans la
capitale ukrainienne
alors il fait peut-être un peu plus
froid à l'extérieur mais à l'intérieur
il fait bien meilleur qu'il y a quelques
jours le chauffage a été reconnecté pour
presque la totalité des foyers dans la
capitale
ukrainienne et selon les autorités de la
ville tout le monde est reconnecté au
réseau électrique aussi donc la
situation s'est stabilisée mais les
interruptions de courant pour faire des
économies pour permettre des réparations
ultérieures donc des interruptions
programmées qui doivent être d'une durée
pas plus que de 5 heures continue à Kiev
est donc 15 régions de l'Ukraine et le
maire qui est vitaliclichko a dit ce
matin que les habitants devraient se
préparer à ce que ces interruptions
continuent jusque dans le printemps et
ça c'est même sans compter la
probabilité très réelle d'ultérieure
frappe russe le porte-parole des forces
des fonds de santé aériennes Ukrainiens
s'est exprimé sur cette question il dit
que les Russes ont besoin d'environ une
semaine ou un peu plus pour préparer
chaque nouvelle c'est pour que leur
enseignement décide qu'est-ce qu'il faut
cibler qu'est-ce qui a été touché la
dernière fois etc et aussi parce que ils
ont un peu besoin d'économie leur
munitions mais selon Youri NAT ils ont
quand même assez domicile qu'ils peuvent
tirer même si les missiles les plus
précis commence à se faire un petit peu
rare en Russie alors si vous comptez les
jours la dernière attaque massive
c'était mercredi dernier ils ont mis
jusqu'à dimanche plus ou moins pour
stabiliser la situation et il est
possible que la prochaine étape pourrait
être aussitôt que dans deux jours
mercredi prochain
merci beaucoup